welcome my friends to this special
edition of honk cast irl of course we
changed the name in solidarity with our
trucker friends and protesters standing
up for freedom individual liberties and
we got big news on this one the latest
is that the ottawa police they want
military intervention but authorities
are concerned they're saying that these
protesters may be armed
that's really fascinating because last
last night we talked about how
the right to keep and bear arms is a
deterrent from government overreach and
because of the potential for protesters
being armed the military doesn't
necessarily want to come in but who
knows things are getting really really
crazy trudeau of course last night once
again smeared the protesters as all the
worst things in the book and it's all
big lies because the reality is this is
a worker revolt a worker uprising we're
seeing a couple interesting things
there's a subreddit called lockdown
critical left asking why it is
that this is an uprising of workers and
the left opposes it and of course all of
these people who are actual leftists are
like yo the left has been co-opted by
corporate interests that's it
and then we have a post from the ottawa
subreddit organizing a protest against
the workers
now they claim to be the left or
whatever but i gotta tell you the
fascists
these are people protesting in support
of government rule by decree major
corporations mandate getting producing
products that the government then
mandates on people
and these people want to support that so
uh yeah fascists we're going to talk
about all that we got cnn man the
president of cnn is out a huge scandal
is erupting brian stelter's blaming
chris cuomo for chris cuomo ratting out
jeff sucker because jeff zucker was
sleeping with the chief marketing
officer who used to work for cuomo's
brother andrew cuomo
whoa scandal cnn's imploding all right
we're gonna talk about all that plus
some news around january six more
subpoenas are coming out with january 6
committee and joining us to talk about
all of this is journalist julie kelly do
you want to introduce yourself
hi i'm julia kelly from naperville it's
tim from naperville aptly fellow
chicagoan
so i am a writer for american greatness
amgreatness.com and for the past year
have been
obsessed with the events of january 6
and the doj's abusive investigation into
january 6 the j6 committee and how
they're using that four-hour disturbance
to launch a war on terror against the
political right which is in my book
four-hour disturbance four hours yup yup
and it has become this insane narrative
among democrats and i love how they say
it's bipartisan because they have liz
cheney like anyone believes it's
bipartisan but they're they're they're
it's insane what's going on now they're
claiming that the the republicans who
signed
elector slates for trump in the event
there was a legal dispute which has
happened before they're claiming they
were forged documents and it's
insurrection they're trying to bar
several member members of congress from
running for re-election claiming they're
insurrectionists you know this is crazy
stuff yes it is that is a political war
and
intended to silence political dissent
and terrorize people into not protesting
the regime you know the resistance
hashtag the resistance was really cool
for like four years remember everybody
thought that was great then all of a
sudden it became you know insurrection
uh on january 6. so this is what they're
doing and we have political prisoners in
the united states
and we have
hundreds of defendants 730 people have
been arrested so far they're adding new
people every day
and this is uh the dojs
you know they're acting as the law
enforcement arm of
the democratic party which they have now
for the past several years so nothing
i'm just gonna i'm gonna say it
civil war
but we'll get into the detail about what
that means because when when you're
accusing when you when you're filing
lawsuits to bar politicians from
re-election that it's not even politics
anymore it's it's it's we're at the
gates of something else but we'll get in
all that stuff we got sheamus sheamus
seamus coughlin of freedom tunes i'm a
political cartoonist i like to make
animations about current events we're
releasing a cartoon about the great
honking tomorrow so i hope you guys
check that out uh and enjoy it and i'm
very glad to be here i think this is
going to be an interesting and
enlightening conversation you're so
serious when you're like you know it's
like you watch
ladies and gentlemen
hello i'm a political cartoonist i make
funny jokes i do these little cartoons
look i start to get wild on the show all
right it's just like i can't come right
out the gates being too crazy people are
going to shut this off that's right
there's only so much zingyness that a
person can have one zane at a time
exactly exactly just you wait thinking
about resistance it makes me think about
the vietnamese and how after the korean
war 1950s they realized they can't
resist the american air force it's
impossible so they had to build tunnels
they had to get out think outside the
box to resist and i see these people
resisting with a with a hammer they want
to walk in and stand there and
resist in the in the old-fashioned way
and then and now i'm seeing this
political hammer come down on these
people there's other ways to resist i'm
interested in talking about that stuff
but we got to get these people out i
mean this is just it's the most it's one
of the greatest travesties of american
history and it's because we're in it i
don't think people realize how dangerous
it is yeah
i
i hate to be you know the negative nancy
on this one but
i think it's going to get darker before
you know no doubt before the dawn but
we'll get into that stuff so ian's
chilling yeah yeah hit me up at ian
crossland.net but first watch the show
yes i am also here pushing buttons in
the corner as i do i love doing that
that is my job and i do think that this
january 16 really kind of puts to bed
the idea that biden winning was going to
bring any kind of normalcy back to the
us especially what they were doing with
rogan too so hopefully we get into some
of that during the show not to mention
biden's approval rating is beyond in the
gutter yeah all right ladies and
gentlemen before we get started head
over to timcast.com and become a member
to help support this show the work we do
all of our journalists that we have on
staff writing news for you every single
day we are principally funded by all of
your contributions as members but as
members you you'll get access to
exclusive members only podcasts from
this show the uncensored version and we
have a massive library of all of this
content you're not going to want to miss
at timcast.com and i also want to
announce we made a new t-shirt based on
the show yesterday so go to timcast.com
click the store and you can get your
very own free hunk hunk t-shirt it is uh
basically modeled after the free hong
kong flag which was several leaves and
they had like the style of art and so we
have made this free hong kong shirt in
two different colors red and black red
and white because it's canada and it
says free hong kong and then we have the
black version which is more like the
hong kong flag so if you want to help
get the message out support the movement
support the great honking
and at the same time support our work
it's greatly appreciated and uh we
really do uh appreciate everybody's
support so don't forget smash that like
button one like equals one honk
and don't forget to share this video
subscribe to the channel and all that
good stuff let's read the latest update
on the great honkening the guardian
reports ottawa police are considering
military intervention to end unlawful
blockade authorities warned bringing in
the military carried a massive risk as
they believe the protesters are armed
what's really really fascinating about
this
let me read this paragraph the ottawa
police chief peter slowly warned on
wednesday that officers did not have the
resources to remove a fleet of trucks
parked by the protesters in the national
capital adding the city was considering
requesting help from canadian armed
forces what did we say yesterday
we said even if they wanted to the
police would not have the means to
remove these trucks and if some of these
trucks are just like just driving my
truck what can you do about it the truck
the tow truck companies reportedly are
refusing to get involved they've said
you know various companies have reported
as saying we have
agreements within the community we don't
want to get involved in whatever this is
but the protests and the government
stuff leave us out of it so you
basically have these truckers in ottawa
along with a bunch of other cars wailing
their horns
and there's nothing the government can
do to stop it the military won't be able
to tow anybody the truckers are here to
stay and uh it's really really simple if
if the people of of uh ottawa
if the government wants it to stop just
comply
if you just comply you'll get your city
back it's not hard it's only two weeks
of honking to restore the freedoms oh i
love it yeah i mean there is just
something so beautiful and satisfying
about seeing the worst
most controlling group of people you've
ever seen in your life not being able to
force their will onto a group of people
it's like they finally found something
they couldn't get past and it's glorious
you know you know i was thinking about
this is video of a guy and he's yelling
i haven't been able to sleep in five
days because of the honking
and i was like i literally don't care
about you guy you sat back while the
government steamrolled by decree all of
this awful stuff that caused strife and
chaos in people's lives and destroyed
their businesses
and now people are honking their horns
the only reason this guy is yelling is
because he thinks he has a right to tell
them to stop
you see he didn't he didn't do anything
to stop the government from steamrolling
over people's rights no but now he's
going to go to a trucker and be like
i'll i'll yell at you sorry buddy you've
got the workers rising up and saying no
if you if you wouldn't stand up for your
rights then what do you think you're
gonna get accomplished look
it's just it's remarkable that
the you you can clearly see the the
dynamics of the political landscape here
the government can do it he won't
complain he says what freedoms have you
even lost
but when the people stand up and create
discomfort now he's mad
you know what go lick a boot dude i
don't i don't care to hear it i'm
thinking about the uh at the end of
world war ii when the americans and the
british were rolling through germany and
liberating the all the i mentioned this
once before on the show all the german
citizens that had just been sitting
standing by and watching it happen were
now getting basically conscripted out of
their houses to go clean up the hot the
the concentration camps and forced to
look at it with their own eyes and see
what this is what they've done they
weren't in an up they weren't in a
position to tell the american troops
stop honking because it was it was had
gone that far we haven't gone that far
yet and hopefully we won't but
you can't sit by and comply with the
tyrannical government and expect when
the cavalry comes in to fix the
situation that you're not going to be
pulled into it yeah well said also can
you believe being like i understand it's
a little frustrating to have people
honking your horns but it's like oh my
goodness the people who bring me all of
my food and literally everything i need
to survive without complaining every
single day i'm making noise when i want
to sleep one time in my entire life i'm
so sorry that that happened to you
sympathetic yes yeah yeah yeah you know
what man the honking will continue until
freedom improves i like that i i
i would be opening my window and and
cheering
yeah
what's interesting is the ruling class
now being exposed for the contempt that
they have for the common man it used to
be
even republicans here democrats
obviously standing for working class
individuals and
them collectively but now they can't
even hide their contempt they can't even
hide their contempt for
who hillary clinton called the
deplorables and now justin trudeau who
won't even deign to meet with these
people saying he doesn't agree with them
like he did the blm protesters
so you just have this global contempt of
the ruling elite finally fully exposed
for hating the people that they're
supposed to protect and defend and i
think that that that's sort of what
happened um
you know on january 6 same thing oh yeah
yeah you know what really really blew my
mind as i was browsing reddit about an
hour or so ago and there was a post
where it said something like oh yeah it
was in in ottawa someone put in their
window it said you know nazis f off and
there's like a swastika with a line
through it right and then i i saw that
and it's a top post and i was like geez
they are laying on their props again
it's so boring but i look i looked at
the comments and the comments on reddit
it's always leftists being like the
right
no the comments were people saying like
there was one guy like this is so dumb
like you know people were saying like
look i get the honking's annoying but it
was literally one guy with a flag
seriously and then someone else was like
yeah but what about the confederate flag
and then all the responses were like we
watched them throw that guy out of the
protest
propaganda's not working i mean we'll
get into it later but cnn just
completely imploding no it's if you dude
if you can't propagandize a bunch of
redditors and get them to accept the
narrative
there's nothing there's nothing no
because
reddit is
such an easily astroturfed platform that
i'm pretty sure
like if you were to ask me based on what
i know about marketing and what's going
on with these social media platforms i'd
be willing to bet
and we do know this is true to a certain
extent
reddit is basically just political
organizations manipulating the platform
to create the perception of popular
opinion and republicans are really bad
at it so they don't and the democrats
are much better at it and big tech works
with them and colludes with them so you
go on reddit man all of the top posts
are like socialists communist far left
everything
it is mind numbing but when even that
stuff isn't working
you've how do you how do you
propagandize people that you're the
workers that you're standing up for the
poor people when it's truckers
non-college educated you know for the
most part people who are just working
class jobs who are bringing let's jam it
said bringing you your food and they're
the bad guys i don't think that
narrative is going to fly so do you
think it's safe to say that they believe
obviously that the next step after
propaganda is to bring in the military
because that's what it looks like to me
remember we were talking about was it
the tales of the economic hitman or
whatever that book was called yeah was
that what it was called ian uh economic
hitman yes like tail like it wasn't
tails but something like that it was
like the store like stories or you know
something like confessions was it
confessions of an academic admin he
basically said that and i'm going to
butcher this but it was something like
first they come to you and ask you to
like be on their side
you reject them then they come back and
say how about some money then you reject
them then they kill you mm-hmm or
something what they'll do is they come
in they try and bribe you to join their
side if you say no then they try and
assassinate you and if they can't then
they should be a full-scale military
yeah
so this seems to be like where we're at
right first they try propagandizing it's
not the exact same thing that doesn't
work now they're trying to organize
counter protests yeah but and they're
already talking about bringing in the
military you'll see they'll probably
single out an individual in the trucker
convoy and then start propagandizing him
because then they're now they're going
to do the ad hominem attack now they did
that oh they did one they did that it
didn't work
yeah so first they smear the whole event
oh they're a bunch of far right racists
then we started seeing posts about like
this organizer is far right associated
with the alt-right and blah blah blah
nobody cared it's getting bigger it's
get the honking grows the honking
continues until freedom improves now
they're talking about military well and
this is what i think happens they've
overplayed their hand to the point where
everyone who sees the propaganda knows
that it's ridiculous and they don't get
that back that's the wonderful part
about it once you over play your hand
like it's not like you get the cards
back people are just never going to
trust them when they talk about anything
ever again and it's beautiful this is
about so much more than just truckers
right and everyone knows that it has
been from the beginning they're
asserting their rights as workers and so
it extends to all other people and all
their fields that are necessary but also
they're really standing up for the
ordinary person of the the nation
they're from and i think other nations
as well and they're also making it
perfectly clear that the average person
does not accept the narrative being put
forward by the media
just wait until q anon shows up in
canada though that is going to really be
a game changer
because that will show everyone that
this is
orchestrated
no i'm joking
i was like wait a minute you know q yeah
i mean
who shows up i'm gonna let you talk i'm
gonna let you say what you have to say
you know enough
that'll be next it'll be no this is the
canadian queue they've already tried
this is russia propaganda right now
exactly and they've had the confederate
flags and they've had the you know then
they had the they had the informant
there who you know they kicked him out
but pretty soon it's going to be cute
but you know it's going to be
canada queue there will be like
candidates
a lady on tv who was like now because of
canada's support for ukraine do you
think russia could be oh my gosh
this is the thing right they only have
so many tricks in their back they're
remarkably uncreative people and the
thing is these tactics have kind of
worked for a little while but more and
more people have been waking up to them
and i think we're finally at the tipping
point where no one believes it anymore
you know i've been looking at anti-work
and work reform on reddit for you know
months now and they're saying like you
know workers of the world unite where
where are these leftist subreddits when
the workers are uniting hold on the
anti-work reddit says why don't they say
like non-workers of the world yeah
really their whole thing the funny thing
is that anti-work initially was
this this radical idea that no one
should work what a job
it's the stupidest thing ever and
they try and act like they're smart
they're like well i was reading a book
by marx and he explains capital when
reality they're like lazy you know
living in their trash departments on you
know government benefits and they're
saying like but i don't want to walk
dogs anymore 20 hours a week we saw that
on fox and that was a pr disaster for
them but it it anti-work evolved into a
work reform subreddit
after the whole debacle where they did
this interview on fox and were exposed
as being
people who just didn't want to do any
work and were kind of lazy
the work reform subreddit took off now i
agree with with a lot of work reform i
think you know the corporate structure
in a lot of ways a lot of really bad
things i think student loan debt has
reached critical mass and the whole
system is broken it has been totally
reformed
but why aren't these people coming out
and being like hey look the workers are
finally rising up this is a really good
thing why don't we we stand in
solidarity with the working class oh
because the actual working class don't
believe in their far left psychosis
their their insane policies they never
have well i mean i think we've we got
the first taste of this after trump was
elected it became apparent that
right-leaning people tend to be more in
touch with what your average working
person actually wants and the democratic
party doesn't really represent those
people now it's as clear as it's ever
been but this was not our our first view
of this
i when i in like 2018 i had an
opportunity to go back to ohio and live
in ohio for a little while i'd been in
like la before that new york chicago i'd
been in these big cities and at first i
was back in like i was living in a farm
town in ohio and my friends were like
trump trump and i'm like trump why
what's going on
what and and it just it hurt it was like
being in like some sort of acid like a
pool of acid it was burning me but i
came out so much stronger because i
wasn't being
manipulated anymore i was seeing things
from this other like workers perspective
that i'd been
just lost had been lost to me in the big
city for 15 years it was really
incredible the power of the worker man i
want to show you guys this uh the
subreddit post from lockdown critical
left yes this is amazing from two days
ago cool spectre wrote workers are
uniting in solidarity against an
authoritarian government and the left is
against it the trucker convoy is the
closest thing to a working class
uprising i've seen in my lifetime i
wasn't around in the 60s and yet the
left is somehow against it isn't this
exactly the kind of thing the left
should be supporting are there even any
working-class people on the left anymore
why do they all seem to be zoom tech
workers or unemployed why is the actual
working class overwhelmingly not on the
left it's really unsettling to see
actual working-class unity taking direct
action against fascist mandates and the
left is taking the side of the fascists
except for those of us who have been
watching for the past 10 years it's
exactly what's been happening the whole
time yeah well it's also i mean to add
another layer here you have the left
literally after uh you know two years
after the the summer of love and these
protests
and all of this anti-police rhetoric
they are now like begging the police to
come in and crack down on a workers well
i guess
yeah now it's atab um it is canada so
you know to be fair it's a different
country but you're right they have blm
protests in canada too yeah and trudeau
stood with them and i'm sorry i'm sorry
kneeled with them
with them yeah so so he bent the knee
why isn't the working class returning
the favor right but of course it's
because blm and these leftist groups
never represented the working class in
the first place yeah so my favorite
author is terry pratchett and he has the
perfect quote about this he says people
on the side of the people capital t
capital p always ended up disappointed
in any case they found that the people
tended not to be grateful or
appreciative or forward thinking or
obedient the people tended to be
small-minded and conservative and not
very clever and were even distrustful of
cleverness and so the children of the
revolution were faced with the age-old
problem it wasn't that you had the wrong
kind of government which was obvious but
that you had the wrong kind of people
and i think that's the left is
discovering entirely i think they've
known this yes for a long time it's why
there was this really funny moment where
in seattle some like socialists came out
and were protesting against amazon and
then some trade workers and construction
guys and contractors showed up in their
vests and hard hats and started chanting
them down
because they were the actual
working-class guys these intelligentsia
you know college graduate types think
they're working class they're quite
literally not they're the intelligentsia
i represent the working class well no
yeah it's also funny because um
the left has always tried to say that
they represented the working class but
then they'll take all of these wildly
unpopular social positions that your
average working person does not believe
in it all and then try to force it on
them so it's like
even with situations outside of this i'm
pro-working class except i think a
working-class person should lose their
job for stating something in a public
forum that literally every other
working-class person believes about
transgenderism for example yeah like
like whoopi goldberg you know they
suspend her she's a good working class
one that's right and they come after her
with this cancer culture it's so obvious
because it really is about money here
she is making a humble 96 dollars per
week yes per week per week and of course
because she has six figures yeah not
even six figures per week and so she
can't defend herself and so she gets
suspended for two weeks it's terrible
heavens when when will the workers rise
up no but but i bring that up real quick
just because as a good example of what
happens toby goldberg when she doubles
down on offensive comments gina carano
on the other hand who didn't say
anything offensive she said don't
demonize your neighbor she loses her job
i thought that whoopi thing was an
example of um critical race theory
having gone too far it went too far
because she all of a sudden is now
starting to think that if someone is the
same skin color as someone else that
they're the same race skin color has
nothing to do with race maybe not maybe
it's not safe to say maybe it's not safe
to say nothing but if you take someone
out of a place on earth and put them
somewhere else within two or three
generations their skin color is going to
be different their kids their grandkids
are going to look way different than if
you put them in like sub-saharan africa
let me let me try and help you out ian
and by make this making this point there
there are uh asian cultures that look
very similar to native american cultures
even though they're they're very
different i came across the bering
strait 13 000 years ago and so it's not
necessarily like you you could be a
different race or ethnicity and look
very similar to so skin color and race
are not the same thing and that's what
terribly they are connected you know you
could say that their core there is a
correlation there it's it's really uh
offensive and egregious that she would
make that claim yeah yeah so there was
related to the way that the left views
the working class there was this book
that i read when i was 17 that really
informed my view on this and it's called
intellectuals by paul johnson and he
sort of goes through
the lives of many of the people who are
held up as like the foundation
or the foundational thinkers
of modern society and what he points out
is that so often these are people who
claim to love humanity in the abstract
but in their personal relationships when
they dealt with actual humans they
tended to treat them like garbage
and i think there's a parallel here
because the left tends to be much more
likely to say i want to change the
entire world i want to reshape the
entire society and change how people
think about things change the way people
treat each other and i think
conservatives are much more likely to
err on the side of subsidiarity
subsidiary and try to change what's
around them as opposed to going for the
world as a whole because they're more
interested in actual individual people
and so these lefties have this idea in
their head of what the working class is
as an abstraction and then when they
have to deal with actual working-class
people and their desires they come to
realize that human beings are messy and
they require that you sacrifice your own
will in order to care for them and
they're not willing to do that you know
i wonder if you know marx has some good
points about capital and stuff and i
wonder if uh
ultimately a bad ideology i'm just but
you know it's it's broken clock is right
twice a day but my point is you get
these these college graduate people that
some of the some of the highest salary
earners in the country in the world
and they're greedy
and jealous
and angry and purposeless so they feel
like something is wrong
something is wrong with my life then
they read you know das capital or
whatever and they're like he's talking
about me
yes because i hate my life he's
literally not talking about you you are
the one
let's let's just be real the
intelligence are the ones who get
executed because they're threats to the
revolution oh yeah no as soon as the new
revolutionary sect rises the power they
end up taking out all the people that
fought for the revolution in the first
place because those are agitators they
were the ones who fermented revolution
exactly yeah
can't have those people in your system
nope well we have this uh this other
post from reddit it's called the counter
protest from r ottawa hello everyone my
name is mackenzie and i am not afraid
this saturday i will be organizing the
peaceful counter protest against the
terrorists occupying our city center
terrorism is defined as the unlawful use
of violence and intimidation especially
against civilians in the pursuit of
political aims people are afraid our
downtown workers are afraid to go to
work the police is afraid the police is
afraid to act the city has denied me an
official protest permit citing covet
concerns i am not afraid
no you're a fascist can i say that
literally a fascist also can can i say
like the most boring thing in the world
but i think needs to be said here like
where where was this kind of talk during
the blm riots like how does that not fit
the definition of terrorism when
buildings are being burnt down i don't
believe this is a real person i don't i
you know i mean it's probably
but come on you know i'm reading some of
these posts on facebook from lefties and
i'm like dude you don't actually believe
what you're saying right like you can't
be that psychotic no they are
yeah i it's a mix well well look what
really is pissing me off right now is
how they're like the school banned the
book mouse and i'm like they literally
didn't ban the book they removed it from
the curriculum you know what does that
mean the gulag archipelago has been
banned as well oh no they're banning the
oh they're they're banning you know
anti-communist propaganda what do we do
no it's just not part of the curriculum
you know what i would say uh to everyone
who's upset about mouse i think and
here's an idea we should have curriculum
transparency to ensure those right-wing
fascists don't go meddling with
curriculums in ways that parents aren't
aware of we should have curriculum
transparency i just saw that there was
far right
right so so making the students
curriculum transparent to the world is
that what it is or just to the parents
to the parents into the community yeah
to the community meaning like it's on
the internet for me to go look at what
anyone could see right i'm open to open
source of course
yeah here's something i don't know do
you guys know how many books are in a
curriculum
that that's that's like a curriculum is
like something they want you to read
throughout the year whatever yeah it
can't be that many yeah it's like four
or five maybe really just four or five
well i think maybe per class or
something yeah per class yeah like per
english class so so you know i don't
want to get wrapped up in that whole
mouse conversation again but you know
just in the context of what these people
are saying when i see this post and it's
like i am not afraid these people are
terrorists it's like dude they're
honking car horns calm down
yeah you wouldn't have to say i'm not
afraid if you weren't afraid you
wouldn't be saying that you're obviously
afraid that's why no no no i am not
afraid no i don't think it's i don't
think it's a real person you think it's
an ai no no
if you put it all the way to the left it
gets you fired from your job what i mean
is this person is lying
they're crafting a political message for
political reasons man i can't put
anything past anybody these days
i was buying it really mm-hmm
because you've seen stuff like this
before no no what you were saying about
the scale yeah i think it might be an ai
yeah yeah i took the political compass
no this is well crafted by a person and
it's probably someone who is
you know liberal left whatever the
canadians call themselves they don't
have democrats or whatever and they're
it's their their version of
establishment communist elite type
authoritarian across the board and they
were like what can we do to push back
against this worker uprising
let's do a popular message let's post
into you know the city subreddit and
then make people think it's a popular
thing for a regular person a regular
person who's like honking your horns is
terrorism
yeah
no but when black lives matter costs 2
billion dollars in damages and killed
around 30 people
maybe then we can call it terrorism and
i also love to throw to you julie the
the january 6 oh oh the police opened
the door and let people walk in the
building terrorism
yeah they got a strong definition don't
they and when protesters like literally
broke down the barriers in front of the
white house and were setting fire to the
church across the street from it that
was not an insurrection that was not
terrorism the president of the united
states had to be hidden away in a
shelter but that was not terrorism or an
attempt at an insurrection
right
well in here it's not just reddit
posters or whack jobs who are randomly
saying that this is terror you have our
fbi director christopher wray who is
designated january 6 as an act of
domestic terror they are comparing
january 6 defendants to terrorists
and so when you have this codified by
your top law enforcement official then
of course that is how it goes mainstream
so you have democratic lawmakers or even
judges just
just say well they were terrorists this
was a terrorist attack and these people
are terrorists so then it everybody
becomes a terrorist right except for the
actual terrorists you know the people
who burn down cities and to your point
two billion dollars in damages um the
fbi has arrested three times as many
people related to january 6 and they
have the entirety of 2020 rioting which
is insane um and you have that you have
chris ray still lying about it saying oh
we're handling both events equally
when we can't read and we can't pay
attention to actually what's happening
just just think about that for a couple
seconds you have people who caused when
we say two billion dollars in damages
that's the maximum the insurance
companies would would pay out it's not
even the total amount the damage could
be way higher when you have estimates
ranging from like 26 to 32 dead in these
riots
they they they burnt down a police
station and the police were forced to
flee
for three months they were fire bombing
a federal courthouse
and
there's no terror declaration there's no
law enforcement dismissing charges
against those people they've already
dismissed about a third of the uh
charges related to portland just think
about that for two seconds and then you
have
you know the magame types who went to
the capitol and the police removed the
barricades the police did that
and you see one cop fanning people they
walk in now there was conflict at the
tunnel people were fighting and we have
we had richie mcginnis on the show he's
a journalist who was there people were
shoving with cops and fighting with them
yelling stuff yeah but then you have
people who are walking up to a door the
police open the door and one cop can be
heard saying i don't agree with it but i
agree with you right to protest as they
all come in walking and bumbling about
the magami mimo types they're the
terrorists
madison cawthorne spoke at a rally for
president trump far away from you know
relatively far away and they're claiming
he was supporting the he was involved in
the insurrection
and the media is on board and the law
enforcement our law enforcement address
is on board when you have
these two very clean uh very two
distinct circumstances
you need to start realizing that they're
at war with you
that they want to destroy your life and
what i mean by that i mean like there
are elements in the fbi not every single
person obviously but you look at the
political landscape there are there are
powerful connections between media and
democrats and i'm not speculating we've
got the cnn story where the woman who
worked for andrew cuomo then went became
chief marketing officer at cnn and was
hooking up with the president and that
whole scandal happens they're obviously
colluding in big tech as well and they
want to ruin your life they hate you
and you just have the news this week
that a top national news editor at the
washington post has to recuse herself
from her job from her position because
she's married to the chief of staff to
the fbi director chris wray
so think about i mean so the
incestuousness
so you have a major newspaper who has
lied about russiagate for years and now
is covering up huge stories like the
whitmer kidnapping fbi kidnapping plot
and certainly has a huge spin on what
happened you know ray ups that's a
conspiracy theory this is the washington
post and then you find out here is she
is married a top editor married to the
chief of staff what do you have
so this was a great paul sperry uh
uh peace investigative piece on real
clear investigations and he details the
whole thing and this man's father is
tied to the clinton machine like it just
you know
they're they're losing yeah people don't
act this way if they're winning
people act this way in power when
they're losing the desperation that's
right like rating james okay the fbi
rate on james o'keefe i'm just like wow
you got to be really desperate to pull a
move like that you do and i mean i think
that that's one thing that our side or
whoever side needs to realize and i talk
with this like people are friendly smith
um when you are a political party and
you're in charge you don't act this way
if you are winning over the masses if
you're convincing them um you know even
30 years ago if you're a bill clinton
and you're charming and you're trying to
actually bring people together at least
one office but this is the this is
actually the last gasp of the left of
the radical left they are they're
desperate and this is why they are
calling people terrorists that's why
they're rounding up
indiana mimas you know this is why
the media is so corrupt and they're
i mean it's all falling apart for them
they think that they're convincing us
that they're winning but they're
actually losing and so that's why
they're it's it's going to get worse
before it gets better i've heard that a
lot meemaw like what is what does that
mean
like it just means like regular person
well i mean there were older women there
um one indiana grandma the mima who went
through the re-education camp from her
court-appointed radical left
attorney and um you know she was a
grandmother of five but there were
elderly older not elderly you know 60
some odd-year-old women who were also
raided by the fbi and charged with
misdemeanors so
that's sort of the joke but there were
just average americans and they were
it was very offensive for those people
to be in the capitol building no i was
thinking about this
2023 is primary season
donald trump presidential primary season
donald trump is already campaigning he's
already got that viral video where he's
like i'm going to be the 45th and 47th
president
and so we know what that is like if you
were to ask me i'd say they planned that
because he wanted people to know he's
running he wants the funds the donations
the interest but he doesn't want to
publicly announce he is it's very clever
or maybe it really was just him and
somebodies were golfing and he and he
said it you know because he wasn't he
didn't care
but this means
if joe biden is not going to be running
for re-election and i don't think he
will be
we'll have to hear something in the next
six or so months because
for donald trump to already be gearing
up and he's doing his campaigns he's got
122 122 million the democrats need to
start raising money
if joe biden is going to run for
re-election he needs to start gearing up
now but he's not
they they're i don't think joe biden can
win again people hate him his approval
writing's in the gutter we what was that
what was the jobs report minus 300 000
minus it was supposed to be did that
happen during the lockdowns wasn't that
like when everything shut down it was
like yeah that kind of figure that's
scary bad but my point is saying if if
if if it is true
that joe biden will not be running for
re-election i think by like june we're
going to hear an announcement if
something's going to happen
yeah
joe biden raised 1.69 billion dollars
for his
re-election or his election campaign
last year is that correct no no no no
you you i'm sorry you have to correct
your job and the dnc it's it's um joe
biden uh didn't raise the money
anti-trump raised them but okay so he
one 1.7 billion dollars and the dude sat
in his basement and didn't yeah do
interviews
was his campaign does that include all
the in-kind donations billions from big
tech who are censoring everyone and
probably not that's scandalous so what
does this money go for trump raised 1.96
billion dollars i he was at least out
there running around doing stuff
julie does this strike you anything
could it possibly be anything other than
political warfare and how bad do you
think it's going to get before the
election with the january 6th all
together i think it's going to get worse
everything around it yeah all of this
stuff yeah i mean i think it is going to
get worse i think it's going to get
worse in two ways they're going to
ratchet this up you already see the
january 6 committee they're desperate
they know their their their time is is
running down as well right their months
are numbered because they're going to
lose the house right so they're going to
do whatever they can they're going to
issue a report um probably two reports
one is that both that will deal with the
insurrectionist lawmakers
they're going to try to
uh suggest new legislation that will
deal with lawmakers who act
insurrectiony in the future
but also they're going to tie this to
election uh integrity reform and so this
has been the basis of january 6th since
the very beginning to tie anyone who
wanted election integrity to tighten up
the rules that uh will happen in 2020 to
that's the report that's that's the
excuse of january 6. well then we need
all these reforms so this never happens
again that sort of thing but it's also
going to get worse i'm sorry it's going
to get worse because the american people
are going to find out exactly what the
government did government actors
agencies political actors who helped
orchestrate what happened that day and
execute it and that is going to be
mind-blowing to a lot of americans so
the democrats are losing so much support
right their popularity is dropping so
much they're not gonna be able to pass
any of this stuff they're gonna try but
they're spinning their wheels
but then they'll just have it out there
right so it'll just be out there these
reports it'll be like the mueller report
they're still talking about the muller
report they want it unredacted like what
do you what
it's over but
but you have insane people on the left
you have millions of those people po i
mean they still actually think that
trump colluded with russia right i mean
you could tell them anything they still
think that the covington kid
disrespected the elder and you know he
should be in prison or something
yeah you know the it's not just the left
the the political ruling class or the
media it's their followers it is their
it's millions of our countrymen who have
completely lost their minds and they
would be happy
not just to have the january sixers in
prison political prison but all of us
they i mean this is what covet exposed
coveted tyranny it's what the 2020 and
it's certainly what january 6 is you
have americans who want this to happen
so let me ask you
you seem to believe that it is going to
come out how deeply involved this state
was with uh january 6th how do you think
the american people are going to respond
to this and what do you think the
government's response to their response
will be that's a great question because
a lot of people say well who cares you
know you're going to have half of the
country who is going to believe from the
beginning it was an insurrection incited
by donald trump but you are still going
to have americans and i think this is
sort of the whole ray ups thing that
that has sort of raised a lot of red
flags for people
who is he why hasn't he been charged why
won't the fbi or mayor garland answer
who he is
so that's raised a lot of questions but
the government's involvement was deep
and it lasted for months
ahead of time um you had something
called the fbi operation cold snap which
was launched in the spring of 2020 to
infiltrate militia groups who are
planning these anti-lockdown rallies so
a lot of it goes back to lockdowns
they had informants in these militia
groups we know that for a fact and
they were responsible for concocting and
executing just like the whitmer
kidnapping probe uh most of what we saw
on january 6 not just the government dc
metro police capitol police muriel
bowser's administration
it was a lot of of independent factors
which is why they kept the capital uh
intentionally insecure that day because
they didn't want thousands of national
guardsmen there saying hey why are you
throwing flashbangs into the crowd you
know why are you shooting rubber bullets
at people outside
why why don't we go inside why don't we
put up the barricades why don't we close
the doors if you don't want them so
that that is why
we didn't have them there i think the
propaganda's failed
you know i think what we what we saw
with joe biden's collapse in popularity
after afghanistan what we saw with you
know the the ongoing joe rogan you know
attempt to censor and everything it's
just not working
and i think regular people
they're just not falling for it anymore
especially like we we read that post
from the lock down critical left saying
like why isn't the left supporting the
worker uprising
the message is getting out they can't
control it anymore i mean cnn msnbc
their ratings are just abysmal
people don't care they're not listening
they've lost what mika brzezinski said
they've lost the ability to control tell
people what to think
you guys remember when you said that
yeah she was like you know he thinks
he's going to tell people what to think
but that's our job that's economic so
economic hit ban hitman war gaming here
that means that that's the first stage
where they're trying to bribe if the if
they think their propaganda is not
working anymore that means that their
bribes have failed now they're going to
go to stage two which is assassin
assassination see like
personnel well not personality
assassinations but like uh what do you
call what the characteristics of
character assassinations absolutely
imprisonment uh against people's will on
judiciously with the patriot act stuff
like that we're in that stage you guys
got to understand how easy it is
to to carry out so so uh let me let me
slow down start over
there was they used to governments all
over the world assassinate i mean it's
world war one and stuff like that we we
know assassinations happen but when it
came to popular uprisings there was a
fear that you would make a martyr
and so you know if you read a lot of the
history books okay so we so we have to
character assassinate we have to make
them not worthy of being heroes
but these days man i mean first of all
there's that story i don't know how true
this is but i remember reading some
reddit meme about the cia's heart attack
gun you ever hear about that oh yeah
yeah it fired like a frozen like a dart
with like a frozen poison that like when
it dissolved would just kill you and
look like a heart attack or whatever
they testified under oath about that
actually yeah it's very very easy to
assassinate
and and get away with it it's it's
ridiculously easy people don't
understand this they they think we live
in this world where like oh they would
be able to do that would be able to pull
it off it's like dude they find a
homeless guy they give a weapon and they
just send them off on his way you know
what i mean
it does raise flags though real
assassinations which is why they go with
the characters and why there's
indefinite detention against like where
people can't even like speak out they're
in solitary so you don't even know
they're being detained
this is why i bring this up because
they've lost control of the narrative
that freaks me out if they like what
what will they do next look at that
regain control drone bombs over cities
like that's the third stage of economics
when you have a little scale yeah but
they're not gonna do that against their
own i don't think so but you never think
the government's going to do that
against their own citizens you never
think
let me let me make my point
they need you to work to produce things
for the system which they want to
control it's like if somebody wants to
own a house they're not going to blow it
up because they can't have it so a crazy
person would and maybe they're crazy
people in government but the idea is how
can we take control of this resource we
don't want to destroy it they're willing
to tolerate some loss
but my point is they've lost control the
narrative so
you know maybe
powerful people and i'm not saying the
grand conspiracy or anything i'm just
saying powerful people get mad and they
they they can be
dangerous they have a military bases all
over the earth and they're afraid of
losing it to china the hegemony to go to
the power to china so they're
desperately trying to crack down on
american descent to maintain the global
military autocracy i do not agree yeah i
don't think they're worried
at all i know they're like china yeah
yeah yeah joe biden is a different level
of people we had who do we have on who
talked about joe biden's you know
cabinet
i think no no no no no well we just had
him on yeah yeah yes he did talk about
you know
but we had we had someone on um a while
ago talking about joe biden's
cabinet has somebody who is very very
pro china and pro trade with china and
all this stuff and if you look back at
like the clinton administration there's
all of those ties and all those
connections
yeah
so
okay
well i do believe that there's a global
movement to unify everything under like
a socio-communist
kind of um corporate
yeah
let's figure out the acronym for that i
think that there are people that with
american nationalists that are afraid of
losing american control of the global
military force i could be wrong about
that i feel like people are
desperate to maintain control yeah i'd
like to ask you one more question um
just about uh you sort of got into what
you think the government's role in this
is when people start to recognize that
how do you think they're going to
respond to people recognizing it i think
we're in a position now let's say this
was five years ago or
maybe even 10 no one would i think
accept that the government was capable
of doing this
that the fbi the intelligence community
the national security state that okay
they'll screw around with people but
they're not going to actually have this
full-scale operation
to shut down what happened on january 6
and then use that to weaponize all of
the tools of war against american
citizens i do think and i think it does
play into the covet tyranny that people
are recognizing
that our government is run not just
political leaders but the people who
populate these agencies the nameless
faceless i mean they're anthony fouches
but there's thousands of them
who are willing to do anything they know
that they can get away with it they
don't care about your kids they actually
want your kids punished they don't care
about your business
they don't care about your future they
will do anything to keep a hold of power
and to get rid of not just threats like
donald trump or his family his cabinet
members but even his 75 million voters
so i do think that people are going to
be shocked when there's more information
that the information already is coming
out in these trials this is why they've
kind of delayed these trials this is why
they're keeping a lot of these men held
behind bars because they don't want them
telling their story
but you can't do that forever right we
learn from russiagate we've also learned
from kovid they can only get away with
fooling people concealing evidence
getting their narrative out there for so
long before it just crumbles and then
everyone goes oh wait a minute this was
all
bs to begin with and it was
we had really bad people in charge of it
yes absolutely i think one key
difference here and i'm glad you
mentioned russiagate because for me that
was really the red pill with respect to
the deep state before that if someone
claimed that the deep state or that
there was a deep state it was colluding
against the sitting president i would
have said that sounds a little bit crazy
sheamus
and and people who work in government
who are there
throughout various administrations and
exert influence you may be right
according to this researcher you believe
in an anti-semitic conspiracy well she
and she does research on tick tock so
it's very important of course yeah but
uh no i mean it's it's true and this
that was a big red bull moment but the
difference here is that with the
russiagate scenario they were going
specifically after people who were
acting within the political system but
with january 6th they're going after
ordinary civilians so i'm curious about
what the fallout is going to be here
because with
russiagate they just stopped talking
about and it disappeared i wonder if
it's going to be more difficult for them
to get away with that given your average
person feels more threatened by what
they've just done here right well they
they the the feds raided some random
woman's home remember that do you know
about that
they've rated hundreds of people's home
but yes
totally totally uninvolved people well
they were there but they had the wrong
person right right right but i mean
they're rating people they're doing
military style fbi raids with armed
agents pre-dawn raids with military swat
teams they have trucks with battering
rams they're not they're by they're
aiming rifles at children they're aiming
them at elderly women they've dragged a
disabled veteran thomas caldwell through
the snow
um and handcuffed him i mean the stories
of what this fbi has done and
it's so it's not just the top of the fbi
right it's throughout it's every single
day
56 field offices have been involved in
this and they are arresting people every
single week they're trying to get to in
my predict my prediction is they're
trying to get to a thousand defendants
by the middle of the summer so this
could be the democrats huge talking
point but to your point seamus this is
ruining people's lives and it's not just
the family that it happens to us their
whole neighborhood knows their company
you know their co-workers know their
church knows everyone sees this it is a
war on terror not just
um how the
tools of government uh authority are
being used but it's also a message to
everyone you know you dissent this is
going to happen to you yup this is it's
it's sounds so similar to the start of
like the bolshevik revolution or you
know the rise of the soviet union
these are the stories that i was told by
my friends who grew up in as children in
you know communism and the stories they
were told by their parents about how
peop you know
it got to the point where if you said
one bad thing about the party or the
government you were taken away
we're not there com yet we still have
shows like this
but we often talk about when we compare
things to history
at what point did people say it's time
to leave germany or or spain for that
matter spain often gets left out of
these conversations a spanish civil war
communists fighting fascists and then
you get military rule for like
generations
at what point do you leave
what do you do
so many people thought it couldn't
happen here and they stayed in their
countries and they paid the ultimate
price mm-hmm
you know and i think so i'm telling you
to leave shame is getting out i know
you're always dropping things
no but i think i think it's not just
about people it's not just about people
leaving it it's it's about people
the people who stay knowing when it's
it's time to fight to stand up for their
country and to say
this is wrong we're going to speak out
against you we're going to resist it we
got going for us here is that we're not
coming out of a monarchy like the the
bolsheviks were the russian revolution
was fighting against a monarchy so they
didn't have much choice but to fight
with physical arms we have a democratic
process of free speech and
things like that in place that can
protect our ability to diplomatically
coerce the system
and you're right and that's why i think
one of the reasons they're they're
scared losing narrative control means
that this this upcoming election is
panic mode for the establishment it's
mostly democrats it is many republicans
because the populist you know surge in
the republican party is not something
the establishment wants
but to your point julie what you're
saying about how they're ramping things
up for the summer because they're
worried if they lose the house in the
senate
they're not just going to lose the house
and the senate to republicans they're
going to lose the house and house and
the senate to republicans like lily tang
williams
we had on the show
who is like this country is becoming
communist and we have to stop it or
marjorie taylor green or lauren
wouldn't that be great and and that's
right
and and that's what they're terrified of
because it's actually happening but we
still have a very weak republican
leadership in the house and senate and
people are very afraid even when they
take over that
this current leadership will not be
capable or willing to do to turn the j6
committee 180 degrees and aim it at the
people who have perpetrated this they
don't want to expose it it's the same
thing
a lot of this goes back to russiagate
because
how we got here is that nobody was held
accountable for what happened in russia
gate except for like michael sussman
like big deal
and you came yeah oh no we've got the
vinman's you know now he's suing trump
and he's like on cnn and so is his wife
um no one's held accountable so
it just got worse and worse and worse
and so
i say we went four years from the fbi
ambushing mike flynn
in the uh white house to ambushing the
hubers you know ambushing veterans in
their in their homes it only took four
years but why because no one was held
criminally responsible for what they did
which was perpetrate the biggest
political fraud in american history up
until january 6th
and and
everybody's off so far you know we've
got some drip drips out of the durham
investigation but
where is that gonna go well maybe
there's going to be a big surge in in uh
november
but not just that it's the state
elections the governorships as well and
we are very very close to a convention
of states the state-level republicans
are very very different from the federal
republican leadership so that could be
something big some people have said it's
a bad idea a lot of people are saying
convention of states is a good idea
because in the states can just take the
power change constitution and make big
moves
but i think the establishment knows that
our processes the processes that were
set up by the founding fathers work
and can save us
well they're not working now i mean
that's for sure especially i mean
there's been no oversight i mean there
has not been but i just interrupt i i
disagree
i think the issue is that culturally no
one's been willing to stand up and use
what's been given to us because they've
been too comfortable and complacent but
now that things have gotten this bad and
the narrative has been shattered there
are mechanisms in place that even the
establishment can't stop
i hope that you're right i'm a little
more skeptical about that because i've
seen i see firsthand how um
you know no everyone basically has been
silent in the face of what's happening
with january 6. you're talking about not
just
the the political end of it in congress
you have this illegitimate committee
issuing subpoenas and they're working
hand in hand with the doj for contempt
of congress charges
et cetera you have joe biden for the
first time ever u.s president has denied
executive privilege to his predecessor
he did it twice he did it based on the
fact that january 6 was so unprecedented
and it went all the way to the courts
and what did the supreme court do
okay we're upholding it so you have
district you have district judges
circuit judges and now the supreme court
who's going along with the left because
they're afraid
so there has been no oversight in the
legislative branch of the executive
branch none
and it has to but they if they take over
they have to make sure they do it this
time because they haven't done it what
has to happen is people need to primary
all of these establishments republican
types and bring in more people like
marjorie taylor green i absolutely agree
i mean i wish we had you know 230 of her
that because she actually will do it and
she feels passionate about it um but
there's still a fear factor there and
i'm afraid that if the republicans do
take the house the senate is useless
senate's not gonna you could have a
hundred republican senators they're not
gonna do anything
because they're all basically lindsey
graham or mitt romney they are
um so it has to happen in the house
and they have to do the same thing they
have to go and zero out they have to
zero out doj's budget you have to zero
out the fbi we are zeroing you out until
we you are done we you're done taking
these we're the trials are over we're
not paying for any more prosecutors
we're not paying for any more arrests
we're not do no more subpoenas to big
tech you're done with this
will they do it
you have to do something that drastic if
people go out and vote in the primaries
go out and vote locally and make sure
establishment politicians don't win
then yeah it's going to be it's going to
be crazy it's not gonna be the
apocalypse that'll be if trump wins
again in 2024 because he's gonna be off
the leash
but if
if if populist
pro-america types win their primaries
and then the republicans take the house
and you get a large portion of the house
republicans as people who say we're done
with this and it's time to go on the
offensive for once
then you're going to see some pushback
you're going to see i think the
establishment plan january 6 done
i think you're going to see republicans
making a bunch of moves with their
subpoena power but it only happens if
people go out and vote in primaries
primaries primaries primary amen
i mean it's true oh it's such a disaster
only
our current republican leadership could
fail
to turn the fact that the deep state has
literally targeted their own
constituents into a political advantage
it's insane
and you're going to watch republicans in
a few weeks they are going to continue
the funding of the government the same
government that is turning
the weapons of war against their own
constituents and that exactly perfect
example the congress including most
republicans just voted last year to give
capitol police 2 billion more dollars
what did capitol police do they turned
around they opened up an intelligence
unit for the capital police you know the
guys who like make sure you put your
purse through the scanner or tell you oh
the capital is that way and there's you
know canon office building all of a
sudden they're like they have a bunch of
spies in this office and they're not
only spying on lawmakers their staff
they're spying on their donors they're
compiling dossiers well why are they
doing that for the same thing they did
in russiagate ukraine gate name it they
they have the authority to do it they're
unchecked they're unaccountable and
they're going to leak that information
to the press right so all of a sudden
this summer you're going to see terrible
stories coming out sourced to anonymous
intelligence officials which happens to
be this capitol police
intelligence unit that republicans voted
to fund
it they don't they never learn let me
let me change the conversation and give
people a bit of a white pill it's a
little a little scary conversation we're
talking about is crazy stuff but i have
a story about the waning power of the
establishment yes an interrupting
scandal over at everyone's favorite
network cnn in this story from
timcast.com cnn president jeff zucker
announces resignation
zucker says he failed to disclose a
relationship with a colleague to the
media company but oh boy is it so much
spicier than that
we have this story from the daily mail
devastated cnn hosts defend jeff jeff
zucker's illicit career ending affair
with staffer allison golist brian
stelter blames chris cuomo for outing
him while allison camarota says he
should not resign
well this is a really fascinating chris
isn't done yet cuomo's lawyer demand to
see emails they believe will prove jeff
zucker knew about his help for andrew
his brother andrew that could cost the
former cnn chief millions of dollars
after sacked host forced him to resign
all right let me let me let me uh bundle
this up for you guys first of all cnn's
ratings are just in the total trash
so the the the tim poole tim cass
podcasts get more viewership than cnn
does by like two or three times that's
how that's how bad cnn's doing
what happens is jeff zucker
you you've got uh jeff sucker who knows
this woman alison uh what's her what's
it what's her lust go lust for 20 years
she works for andrew cuomo right then
she leaves to go work with him in cnn
chris cuomo is then trying to help his
brother with this big scandal they cover
it up
chris cuomo gets caught doesn't get
reprimanded all of a sudden we're now
learning that they're all in it together
they're all one big happy family jeff
zucker then comes out fires chris cuomo
chris cuomo it seems feels betrayed like
yo what are you doing like come on man
you know allison she worked with my
brother and we helped you out so then he
then he publicly he comes out and he
says
zucker was in a relationship with her
and he didn't disclose it so then he's
forced to resign i think there's a
bigger scandal behind all of this
because this shows that cnn is directly
colluding with democratic politicians
democrat politicians
so that's i think there's more to it
than just this and we're just getting
the tip of the iceberg on this one but
cnn
imploding in real time from their top
hosts to the present of their company to
the connections they have with
democratic establishment all being
exposed
let that be a good day for all of you to
see the just the eruption in front of
your in front of your very eyes if they
cnn was a prime vector for russia gate
misinformation for ukraine gate
misinformation and now
and kavanaugh and all that stuff and
defensive blm uh rioting and all that
stuff
not only does nobody watch them anymore
but they can't they can't even keep the
the ship together it's sinking baby
that's beautiful i'm here so so
how many views do they get
so uh i looked up this is totally
independent of these stories i looked up
their ratings their total daytime
viewership
443
000 viewers i believe this number no and
their total prime time viewership is 663
so daytime's usually way lower but this
is a lot daytime is a lot a lot of hours
but prime time is when everyone's tuning
into the news so they're only getting
just over about a million views but get
this they only get around 230 000 key
demographic views
per day
230 000 people between the ages of 25 to
54 watch cnn on a given day that's it
that's that that's how abysmally so i
was saying this before the show i was
like yo
one segment that i do that we do so on
my tim cats news channel we average like
250
unique views
and key demo views one segment i do on
my channel gets more than cnn's total
key demographic daily viewership
sheamus said to me is like stop bragging
and i said no no no it's not because i'm
doing well it's because cnn's collapsing
no no and tim does all that without any
sex scandals either and like
these people can't even get a fraction
of the viewership without doing
something creepy no but it's true i mean
uh it is kind of remarkable to see how
abysmal their views are and it's it's i
mean it's also a white pill i'm not
really yeah i don't want to get too too
down on zuck zuck zucker for this one
because i think he really loved that
girl i mean they've been together for 20
years is that right no no no no no no no
they've known each other
and they've been katie couric said they
were joined at the head yeah so
apparently they're like your friends
they were like only recently he's saying
they started you know oh so it's like a
little will they or won't they kind of
thing for a while
escape the friend
what was that joke you had earlier
sheamus i don't remember you were like
uh he said that he should have revealed
the relationship sooner and didn't and
you were saying like the judge oh my
gosh yeah no she was like
it was a
miscommunication she talked to
management was like he was like you know
we're just like talking it's not you
know i mean he wouldn't define the
relationship and she's like well i know
who will well no yeah you were saying
like i'm gonna tell cnn the manager goes
to jeff zucker and says
are you in a relationship with this
woman and then she turns it on
that's right that's right that's right
we were talking about we're just like
yeah
he's like
the executive's like so what are you
guys she's like yeah jeff what are we
like what's uh what's this he's like oh
and then he's like
just in on his face real slow yeah
yo this is this is a ridiculous scandal
i think i think he's like is this like
an easy pass for him to get out yeah
well he wanted to quit but here's the
crazy thing they were saying this woman
um this woman uh alison gallusta our
goalist was going potential go lust was
potentially going to replace him as
president so this was months ago earlier
last year they they were like
you know she may be tapped to be the new
president when he steps down because he
was talking about leaving for some time
and all of a sudden he's leaving because
the whole thing is imploding yeah so if
nobody watches cnn where do they get all
their money from i'm genuinely curious
you know subsidy
is isn't it also completely insane
isn't it completely insane that the
people who make all of their money lying
all the time don't conduct themselves in
an upright manner in their personal life
that's so bizarre who would have thought
i would think they'd be honest who would
have thought that like you can't trust
people who you can't trust people are
calling for brian selter to be fired or
quit resign why because he was he
avoided reporting on this this ongoing
major scandal at his own network that
people have known about for some time
well he feels sorry for you was that him
during the project veritas video in
their photos like i feel sorry for you i
feel sorry for you brian stelter i
believe it was stelter
they confronted him like it was a
parking garage something when you're
yeah he's like i feel sorry for you i
feel sorry for you you're just trying to
get away super condescending when you
arrest a murderer you don't cut off the
finger that he used to pull the trigger
that's stelter's the finger
well cnn's though is the villain yeah
yeah well no i'm kind of joking because
you could always
terminate uh brian stelter can you
imagine if he did report that story on
air though
the president of this company my boss is
in a secret relationship with the chief
marketing officer everyone here knows it
but no one's saying anything because
we're scumbags i feel sorry for them
yeah i feel sorry for them look the
bigger the bigger story is that cnn's
one of the principal propaganda machines
and it's just like we are sitting we're
sitting on the here's here's what i want
you i want you all to imagine this
it is a warm summer night we're all on
the beach
there's a nice fire going all right
that's a nice fire going it's it's it's
it's not too warm and uh you know your
friend reaches over puts their hand on
your shoulder and hands you a nice cold
beer and you all look off into the
shoreline and you see a gigantic [ __ ]
that says cnn just sinking and in flames
and then everyone holds up there
that's like all right first of all i
cannot condone that kind of that's all
right that's really fun do you remember
when someone made a meme of where they
like photoshopped the cnn logo onto a
wrestler's head and trump was punching
it and cnn literally docks him yeah and
then
they banned the video
they banned the video they doxed this
kid and then they reported on their own
boxing thinking it made them look good
they're like yeah we found him he'll
never do this again sorry for him they
didn't doctor they threatened him yeah
they said we know his name right that's
right if he agrees to never do it again
we won't release his name everyone was
like yo
crazy crazy didn't chris wallace just go
to cnn yeah
that was that was a good move well he
was just like i would like to jump on
that super shrimp
and then he did perfect timing yes okay
you know i i i wake up in the morning
and uh i get out of bed i turn on the
keurig and it pours me out we use
biodegradable curry cups they're very
very it's true they're disgusting and i
think it's fantastic and then i get my
coffee and i put some cream in it and
then i take a sip and then i walk over
and i walk over to my computer and i
press the button and turn the screen
saver off and i see big story you know
cnn ratings in the gutter wracked by
scandal and i just look up i say
it's going to be a good day oh yeah
[Laughter]
and i get to work and
oh man it feels good it does because no
it does it's really it's really yeah
it's really frustrating to see uh you
know we can talk about the joe rogan
thing where brian stelter is like we
have a newsroom and we try so hard and
people just trust joe rogan because they
don't trust us like oh poor baby you
know i love to see it you love to see it
man you guys they lied every every day
about russia they've staged they staged
chris cuomo's quarantine they pretended
he was in quarantine they lied they know
they lied brian stelter knows they lied
these people are evil their actions are
intentional we all know it and we are
all gloating in their glorious
sinking ship it's more than that
watching their glory yeah we're watching
it saying here's the other thing though
it's not as if they just lied right they
have never acknowledged or apologized
for any of those lies even though they
scolded you for believing that they were
lying the entire time that they were
lying and so i'm not just watching this
gloating i am genuinely happy that there
are fewer people consuming their lies i
want to give a shout out to our good
friend michael mallis he says
white pill after cnn decided to take on
joe rogan both the president and most
popular host were driven out of their
jobs
mess with joe you gotta go
there you go i love it that's perfect i
love when people are saying uh denounce
the honk and you get the bunk uh yeah
cause that's the conservative leader got
outside whatever yeah he's doing good
mottos
well i think this is so ian was saying
before the show that he didn't really
want to cancel people like cnn and i
think that um this is actually a form of
actual justice not social justice right
because they've done nothing but lie we
know they've done nothing but lie you
can see chris cuomo coming up out of his
basement when we know for a fact that he
was in a fight with a guy on a bike in
the hamptons two weeks before right we
know he wasn't quarantining we know
they're all lying they're just full of
garbage and this is finally come up it's
for them and yes it does feel good
yeah that's true
he said that was like the n word for
italian yeah exactly it is
it's not but it's very not
it's like very much not it's not even
close you're dumb
oh man so cnn lied over and over again
claiming that joe rogan took horse
medicine they all know they lie yeah and
when i see these posts on facebook
they're like joe rogan took horse
medicine and then i comment i'm like you
know he didn't right like you know a
doctor prescribed him tablets and
they're like yes but the medication in
the tablets the same medication they use
for horse medicine so i'm just making
slight point you know you're lying dude
yeah like what what what what into his
mouth is horse medicine what comes out
of your mouth is horse crap there you go
literally never an honest word fire
also wait that there's something there's
yeah yeah
there was something i wanted to mention
here um but my train of throat thoughts
good duration
my train of thrones oh no i just want to
say one thing about with ian to be fair
ian kind of turned around on that point
before the show about cancel culture one
thing that drives me crazy uh is this
left-wing talking point where they say
cancel culture is just about
accountability even though they're just
trying to get like average working-class
people fired from their jobs or
political activists they don't like
punish for things they said 10 years ago
and then when we're against cancel
culture anytime we want someone to be
punished for an actual crime they go
i don't thought you guys were against
cancer you think you think people should
be punished for actual crimes that
they've committed or should be thrown
out of the
i thought you were against organization
people for 10 year old tweets what's the
deal hypocrisy much yeah i i i i want to
say first i want to show you the story
from rolling stone ian i got bad news
for you
crosby stills nash and young reunite is
removing their music from spotify no
we support neil and we agree with him
that there is dangerous disinformation
being aired on spotify's joe rogan
podcast
what information
what what what what did joe say
what disinformation you don't even watch
the show none of these people do
to go off what you were just saying ian
we need to stop stop pretending that
these people are being serious
they have no idea what they're talking
about they have no idea why they're even
mad all they know is someone on the tv
said joe rogan bed they went uh i'm down
for some free press yeah and that's it
well i mean to be fair tim i think that
their target audience is most at risk
for covid yeah dude it's so good seeing
those guys together that's true and and
you know what um
these are this is the demographic that
watches cnn exactly so they see all the
lies they walk right into it look man
i'm gonna listen to it on amazon so i
gotta say
joe came out he did not apologize for
his guests he said they were
credentialed he said i'm gonna have
these conversations but he said he said
this is really funny he was like i'll
try to balance it out make sure we have
you know a more established
establishment voice or something like
that effect uh the following show so if
they do robert malone they'll have
someone else on and it's just like
joe
you're saying that
the one time
out of you know 100 guests you have one
critical opinion you're going to add in
another one of the 99 mainstream
majority opinions everyone's already
heard like you know joe pointed out he
had sanjay gupta and mike osterholm on
his show and then he had peter mccall
and dr malone it's like so you split it
up pretty well
but they're not satisfied with that
so when he you know gives you makes some
concessions and spotify says okay
they wanted a misinformation policy will
do it it doesn't matter
spotify came out and said okay okay
we'll do your misinformation policy and
now crosby stills and nash join in and
getting their musical get rid of it
they're not going to stop because they
don't know what they're talking about
they are not talking to you spotify
these these these activists are not
saying spotify we have a demand they're
saying hey guys i'm yelling at spotify
right now that's what they're doing
they're not communicating with any of
these people they don't know why they're
mad they don't know why it matters all
they know is their virtue signaling to
activists they want to spend money on
their music and give them press because
they're has beens and then what ends up
happening is you get 30 people on
twitter who never buy your product and
then the company goes 30 people on
twitter are complaining about our
product better pull it they were never
going to buy your product in the first
place so it's just frustrating when
people keep giving in to obvious bs and
they don't stop when will people learn
when will anyone learn that when they
come out and say we demand you do this
if you go okay i'll do it ah now we do
man you do this then this uh next we
want these things we have this the list
of demands it's never going to end until
you say shut your mouth you're deleted
if as soon as as soon as i said pull my
music spotify went you got it buy delete
and then crosby stills and nash comes
out and says we're going to reunite say
have a nice day you're old anyway buy
just tell them to shove off
you know look i i get it spotify is
going to lose money
they lost share their shares went down
because of the controversy
many of these lefty you know people will
pull off the platform they knew that was
going to happen when they signed joe
rogan in the first place so make no
concessions well yeah also i i mean i
have a hard time believing that before
signing any kind of contract with
spotify joe rogan didn't consider this
possibility and ensure that he would not
be removed from his platform because
some know nothing celebrity said he
should be
i think that would be that would be very
i really mean it i could i would be very
surprised if there was anything that
spotify could do
well to me this just looks like a bunch
of old or out of touch artists who are
like oh here's my chance to get two
minutes of fame because somebody
somebody said india ari took her music
off spotify and married trump to i have
no idea mary trump took her podcast
who knew she had a podcast
for young people who want to you know
try to get a spotify account upload some
of their music there's more opportunity
that's right
you're competing for less audience
self-regulation for more audience
actually
about crosby stills nash is again
exposing the hypocrisy of the left these
were the counter culture right back in
the 60s
um the baby boomers the anti-war you
know freedom etc and now they're just
aged you know grumpy
old men who are trying to you know cut
down the young upstart um it just once
again the left is just full of hypocrisy
these are the guys who you know 50 years
ago were leading
you know music's attempts to you know in
the 60s they were
they were powerful in terms of their
messaging and now here they are trying
to didn't know i mean who would have
seen this coming but it just exposes
what the left is did neil young have a
free speech tour yeah i think he did
yeah i watched him talking about covet a
couple days ago and he was like we we
can beat this thing his voice is way
higher than you think when you listen to
him talk
we can we can beat it i know we can we
can do it and it's like what is he
talking about beat this thing you don't
talk about like the common the rhino
virus like we're gonna beat this thing
it just is there they don't even know
what they're talking about i mean they
couldn't even put two sentences together
and make sense of anything but this they
got their headlines and
that's all they care about you just
gotta stop letting like
for whatever reason
people seem to think that the kid
throwing a temper tantrum on the on the
playground demanding that you give him
the basketball is going to stop having
temper tantrums when you when you give
him what he wants it's like dude when
the baby starts crying and screaming
like the the toddler comes in screaming
i want ice cream you got to be like you
can't have ice cream for breakfast and
they'll scream and they'll cry and then
you just feel like it's that's not doing
anything for you what if i'll tell you
eight hours later
of misinformation like nope sorry no ice
cream i used to enjoy it you're four
years old when did you learn my parents
i was lucky that my parents would punish
kids like that and they'd just isolate
them and make them suffer and cry
through the whole thing until they're
done crying but like what if the kid
keeps crying and keeps crying and keeps
crying they used to beat them they can't
yeah well they eventually
they need ice cream as fuel don't keep
trying they'll run out you know what
happens when a kid is crying i'll tell
you this when a kid is when a toddler is
crying a young kid you know saying i
want something
and you say well you can't have it and
they keep crying and you walk away you
know what they do as soon as you walk
away stop they stop crying and look
around to figure out where you went
right why you weren't giving them
attention because crying doesn't work
they figure out crying doesn't work and
they'll stop they'll try something else
so you can't when when when the baby
starts screaming and crying you cannot
give the baby what they want you gotta
get to be a responsible adult and say no
no
no crosby stop it which is
exactly exactly i understand why you're
sad which is
literally exactly going back to our
earlier story why the truckers need to
stay the course and why we cannot buy
their bs about these people being nazis
or white supremacists or whatever
because that is their temper tantrum
exactly ignore these whiny babies yeah
they're like i haven't slept in five
days and it's like well i can't cross
the border anymore so deal with it yeah
well and here's the thing so if you are
one of these truckers protesting you're
actually giving them a good thing in the
same way that a parent who ignores their
child's temper tantrum is giving them a
good thing because these left-wingers
who are slandering you and making
ridiculous accusations about you as soon
as they start to realize that those
really aren't going to work
some of them some small minority maybe
even many of them are going to actually
try to pursue real strategy for
affecting the change they want to see in
the world and i think it's going to make
them more responsible adults and it will
actually reorient their goals away from
leftism so you're helping them
i just want to say i i don't want to be
to become better
i don't i don't seem overly pessimistic
on this because i'm frustrated with
these weirdos let me see if i can uh
pull up joe rogan real quick on
instagram because i want to show you
guys something that's a total white pill
is it just joe rogan on instagram is it
gonna work yeah let's see if it works
all right so where's that post he made
all right we got this post from him so
one of the most important things about
joe rogan's statement on spotify is that
aside from people like you know tulsi
gabbard and tim dillon who are very
obviously fans and friends of his if you
scroll down through joe rogan's post
all of these people
tons of people tons of verified
instagram users are all like joe we love
you you're the best we're on your side
i was looking i was reading an article
and it was like here's a list of
celebrities who came out in defense of
joe rogan on his instagram post saying
awesome things about him and it's like
crosby stills ne and krabi stills and
nash joining neil young
yo you guys are on the wrong side of
history as the left likes to say joe
rogan's got mainstream look at jewel you
guys know jewel what was that just a
beautiful voice yeah you're doing a
great job on a show and it was so good
yeah she's good yeah
it's not like she's the biggest
celebrity in the world right now but
you've got look at all right now you
have high hopes look at all of these
verified users some obviously we know
christina
who's that christina p that's tom
segura's wife well there you go she's
awesome all of the there's a whole bunch
of mainstream celebrities jamie kennedy
ufc fighters who are like joe's awesome
joe is winning this one even when he
comes in and and can see you know uh uh
seed some ground there i'm not a big fan
of it but the point is as much as it's
annoying to see look you got kelly
slater
surfer
they're just they're not they're not on
the side of these crackpots we are
winning free speech is winning the the
right to free inquiry freedom of
association it's all winning and as
michael malus said when cnn took on joe
rogan their president and the host of
their biggest show got ousted so boom
yeah
victory yeah how wonderful
it feels great i can't wrestle with that
i i think you know uh i saw a po i saw a
news story and it was talking about all
of the celebrities cheering on joe rogan
and i'm like that's the message people
need to hear that with all the stuff
going down and all of these media
outlets being like oh joe did this and
joe did that and these celebrities are
angry you gotta see the bigger picture
what are high profile and regular people
actually saying
they don't believe in the cancel culture
they don't care for it they're fans they
love his show he's got 7.6 million views
on his post he's winning yeah kevin
james kevin james oh really
yeah kevin james and how many new
subscribers how many people have never
heard of him before
before this kerfuffle yes exactly i mean
usually this stuff always backfires too
which the left never figures out so it's
like pick your fighter this guy who you
know you have people like grandma wait
who's this joe roll all right i'm gonna
sign up subscribe to him yeah um oh
crosby's still the nash wait what have
they done for the past 50 years
so it always backfires so he's picking
up new uh attention he's picking up
support he's picking up new viewers and
it's just completely backfiring on them
once again you know what oh no you go i
was just gonna say i i can't help
feeling that joe rogan is right now the
voice of populism which is highly
encouraging because to see all these
celebrities being on board with him and
also to see all the normal people who
completely agree with him very
encouraging i do think that we are
waiting on this i just wanna i just
wanna pull up this one more post to make
sure everybody knows oh yeah
from the associated from the associated
press
no evidence video color was manipulated
in cnn news segment september 10th and
then this post showing cnn's version of
the video with joe rogan makes him look
like he's dying he looks like a smurf
yeah
we didn't edit that no it's not that's
how it looked when we got it experts say
they're trying to argue that it was like
oh but people looked on different
devices and that's why it looked that
way wow i took i i did the experiment
myself i took joe rogan's video on the
same monitor same computer screen and i
and i played the video i screen grabbed
it and then i took the cnn clip and i
screen grabbed it you can clearly tell
they're different by the way i put them
into a graphic uh uh uh illustrator
program vectorized the images and then
analyzed the color palettes to break it
down whoa and you can see it is
manipulated he literally in the top
photo he looks like one of those guys in
the artsy hipster part of the city that
dresses as a statue and like stands
around for money that is not how a
normal human looks without editing he
looks like oj like trying to do his own
video but like he's got the camera in
the wrong spot
but but this is just the point when all
of these mainstream personalities high
profile celebrities and regular people
are like you rock the narrative doesn't
make sense when the ap is like there's
no evidence and then you look at it
you're like yo i have eyes i can see it
i know who are you going to believe uh
us
yeah but one thing i wanted to mention
piggybacking off what you said a moment
or to respond to what you said a moment
ago about the fact that um
they
don't seem to understand that they harm
themselves in their message by going
after these people because they end up
promoting them i think the reality is an
infant throwing a temper tantrum or a
toddler throwing a temper tantrum isn't
all that concerned with the optics yeah
and if they got to the point where they
could be concerned with the optics they
wouldn't be throwing the tantrums
anymore if it's but if the tantrum's
working then why do you care you know
like it works it works exactly and
they've been spoiled for way too long
and people are starting to go okay no
like i have to go to work i have to do
my job i'm not listening to this
think about what we're watching right
cnn has a temper tantrum
joe rogan responds very calmly and and
positively and says i'm a fan of neil
young it's great music sorry if i made
you mad guys you know we'll do better
very adult very mature the temper
tantrum doesn't work imagine you're
watching to you go to an ice cream shop
and you see one kid screaming and
banging on the counter give me ice cream
yeah and then the other kid is like
mother if if i get an extra scoop of ice
cream i promise to do my chores when we
go home you're going to be like oh that
kid's very well behaved and that kid's a
little little
you know what i mean that's what we're
seeing from the outside you're watching
cnn have this tantrum and you're just
like they've lost their but the reason
why kids have perpetual the kids who
have the tantrums all the time have the
bad parents who respond to it right so
that's the lesson so as a mother you
know then you don't you walk away you
don't even gauge the kid the kids who
have the perpetual tumbler tantrums are
the ones with the mom who keeps
appeasing them so this is what's
happening you got it you're talking
about a bunch of toddlers
if you've got kids
if you've got kids
and and you know they're complaining
that they want something you got to make
sure you get the paperwork drawn up that
the the eyes are dotted the teaser
crossed and you make them sign that
contract and you you litigate everything
and say don't cry don't cry do the
paperwork you want one scoop of ice
cream well i want the dishes done so
sign here all right initial there
initial there all right we have a
contract here's your ice cream and we'll
get the dishes done let's also teach
them a good lesson about how corporate
world works yeah really the longer the
image is up the more astounding like
like what what kind of middle school
shenanigans is that like i don't like
him so i'm going to make him look like
drax
that's the most obnoxious let's make him
look ugly in the picture yeah he looks
ugly now dude i remember when i i when i
first heard the story about how they
decide they changed the color i didn't
see it from joe i didn't see it from
anybody i was i was watching the cnn
video
claiming he took it says he took horse
dewormer right there from they're lying
and i watched the video and i was like
yo joe looks bad yeah and then i look
like i don't want that horse demonic
stuff right right
yo
it's so insanely obvious what they're
doing i feel like you know we're all
popping out of the matrix and they're
like stop no don't exactly people just
started waking up to the insanity of the
alive i feel bad for regular people who
are still trapped in there yeah you know
and they think they think they think
they're right because you've been
trusted but how do they respect so so
let's say it's the case because trying
to look at this from the lens of
someone who still trusts cnn and maybe
i'm giving them too much credit here
with respect to critical thinking
abilities right yes but
if cnn
put this on air and they really didn't
edit it he just happens to look like
he's from a different species in it but
they didn't notice that and still want
to air with it that's almost just as bad
because at the end of the day you're
getting false information as a viewer so
i'm really curious how the people who
are die-hard fans of this network or who
are loyal to it would respond to
something like this could respond to
something like this
cnn told me that they are the most
trusted name oh yeah they told me that
too and that's and to be honest it might
be true and it's a low bar this is very
long and they told me about that apple
remember that this is an apple
version i didn't know remember when
donald trump was elected right yeah they
were like this is an apple it's just an
apple or whatever and it's like we're
not fake news like we showed you an
apple or something told you it's an
apple
i do remember when don lemon was like
now it may be preposterous but was the
plane swallowed by a black black hole i
know and then and then the lady on the
cnn goes well you know even a small
black hole would swallow the whole
universe what i'm not kidding that
actually happened
and i'm like yo first of all there's no
way a black hole swallowed the airplane
second of all a small black hole would
not swallow the entire universe or else
we wouldn't have a universe like that or
we wouldn't have black holes
you know this isn't that complicated
do you think the jet got swallowed
let me just i just i i kind of feel bad
right now because no don't we get more
views than cnn does we're punching down
oh you're right we're bullying cnn we
need to
we should bring cnn on the show to help
them get more get the word out about
their channel and maybe maybe they'll
get more subscribers oh my gosh bring
john cnn on yeah
the man himself sucker has no ties now
maybe he'll come on and
speak all for us look i did the
photoshop it was microsoft
he wants revenge on chris cuomo now for
costing him his job
chris did that photoshop he's been
messing with premiere a lot lately
whatever what if he came in like a big
stack of documents i was like here's
everything
this is all like furry fanfics
on every story they've ever run they
have the truth as like
when you write the news you you write it
and then they write the fake version and
archive the real story and then publish
the fake one and they're like well so
remember that one story about trump
here's the actual story we actually do
for reference yeah for reference well
it's because they want to know the
history
exact opposite you know
so i i thought about how crazy it is
with all the fake news think about how
it's going to impact history and people
are going to believe the lies forever
it's going to be 100 years they're going
to be like donald trump was colluding
with the russians that's right i know
and that was cnn dude remember cnn was
the first network and january 10th 19
what year was it not 19
2017.
uh january 10th 2017. they ran the i
think they won an award for it i think
they won a pulitzer prize
about the dossier and the briefing that
jim clapper did with trump uh uh and
with jim comey to tell them about the
russian p tape right so this oh that's
right so this really launched the the p
tape the dossier buzzfeed also published
it that day but cnn was responsible for
really launching russiagate
and legitimizing it saying that clapper
and comey had met with trump and alerted
them that they had compromise on donald
trump and so that's where that that's
where it started also this is this is
good karma yeah also middle school
behavior like i'm going to say some peed
on him like he's just nonsense like
complete disgusting nonsense totally
depraved how insane was that
hold on do you remember the story from
the huffington post where it was like a
tape exists of trump somewhere doing
something in an elevator no where he was
we don't know and what he did is un you
were unsure of but he did it but
journalists know what happened and
they're trying to find out what it's
like but again millions of americans
still believe that that happened yeah
they still believe that there's a tape
with donald trump at the moscow ritz
with prostitutes urinating in front of
him they're like yeah that tape that
he's there
hold on uh i gotta i gotta be honest i
honestly do believe that trump will have
done something like that in his life but
whether it's the actual tape of it and
the circumstances they've proposed well
that's outrageous right well
the reason it works is because donald
trump is a crazy guy yeah well you know
yeah no and that's why people believe
that's why they believe right does he i
don't know yeah doesn't he have a golden
toilet yeah
yeah so well i want to say one thing you
mentioned uh history and it's true that
there are probably a lot of things in
our history books that were just part of
media propaganda and we believe them
today however i will say this the new
york times tried as hard as they could
to cover up the whole little more and
that still came out the new york times
also very much under reported on the
holocaust that still came out so
i think it doesn't always happen it
doesn't always happen but i really
genuinely believe that when we need it
the truth does come out but but but
sheamus
think about what you just said then
think about the new york times lying to
get us into the middle east
they're still around
no i know they are not all of those
things it's true and people are still
like i'm going to read the new york
times but that's also maybe you
shouldn't i agree with you but i think a
big part of that was because prior to
the internet your average person who was
aware of these lies because they found
them through research couldn't point
them out yeah and it was hard to find it
was hard to research because they were
the arbiters of morality and truth
exactly but now we are in a different
age and information has been been
decentralized so with that being said
smash that like button honk the like
button one like is one hunk yes and
we're gonna go to super chat so don't
forget to subscribe to this channel
share the show if you'd like to support
our work and go to timcast.com become a
member to directly help us out
make sure that we can keep doing the
work we do and we're going to have a
members only uncensored podcast going up
around 11 p.m tonight you're not going
to want to miss it now
let's see what y'all have to say in the
super chats i think uh there's a lot of
honks yes wimplow says honk all right
that's a good super chat yep yep all
right bobby bob says good luck to the
counter protester i don't think they
will be able to be heard you know what's
going to happen the counter protesters
are going to show up and they're going
to have like lefty signs like saying
down with fashion or whatever but you're
not going to be able to hear a word they
say is the horns are honking so everyone
will assume they're actually part of the
same protest like what are they going to
do you know what i mean
everyone's going to be hey look more
people showed up
all right
recre morrison says it's cold up here
hong kong needs hoodies and tokes yes oh
we should we we should make a free hong
kong sweater and yeah oh uh jessica did
oh she did yeah hey looking at how much
they're earning they're doing great
made a hoodie yeah so stickers if i kind
of want to i don't know if we can do it
in time as the issue but i wanted to
send a bunch of the hoodies up to people
yeah that's great i don't think we can
get a maiden time is the issue oh maybe
not because it takes like several it
takes like three weeks uh to get them
all to get them shipped and sent because
if you do a big order but uh you know if
you need a hoodie free honk hunk uh
do they do flags i don't know i want to
get a free hong kong flag oh that's just
yeah it'd be fun we'll we'll put we'll
like we'll put up a flag post like put
it in front of the castle and just like
have this big flag that's free hunk
free honk hunk
all right let's read some more super
chats
christopher noll says black stones would
you rather would you rather imprison an
innocent person for a crime committed by
a criminal or imprisoned a criminal for
a crime that never happened
is it oh i see what you're saying with
blackstone's formulation
yes blackstone's formulation i guess i'd
rather imprison the criminal for a false
for crime other than the one that he
committed than an innocent person for a
crime that he didn't commit neither
neither yeah neither oh i didn't know
that was an option it's always an option
ian it's always an option i refuse you
can reject a false dichotomy
i don't want to see you held hostage by
these kinds of hypotheticals all right
bill clinton
bill cox says tim if the military
intervenes without proof that the
protest is no longer peaceful they're in
violation of section two of the canadian
charter of rights and freedoms right to
peaceful assembly hunk
yes yeah but i don't know if it matters
at this point
i mean that stuff doesn't matter right
look it doesn't january 6 is a really
great example of it not mattering it
doesn't on uh as sheamus mentioned they
went to the white house they tore down
the barricades they set fire to a guard
post they set fire to the church across
the street the president was was rushed
down to a security bunker injured
federal agency
that's right
exactly and then when aoc like literally
made up a story they're like oh she's so
brave you know what regarding the um aoc
lied about the entire story she made it
up but isn't that telling isn't that
telling though um
there's something very interesting here
when trump actually had to be rushed to
shelter he was in a vulnerable position
he didn't advertise that because i think
real leaders know you should not
advertise your vulnerability
whereas aoc wants to appear as a victim
which is why she can never be a good
leader and let's remember what happened
after lafayette square they didn't call
those people insurrectionists or
traitors or whatever congress held two
hearings against the police about what
happened in lafayette square all the
rioting charges were dropped against
those people and they were attacking
federal officers on federal property
leading to in front of the white house
in front of the white house trying to
jump over the fence and um but they held
hearings in congress not about the
insurrectionists but about
about uh the police people how they
behave people are literally like trying
to break into the white house like do
you think you might have overreacted
there in your response
all right remember that
yeah the press briefing yeah we got matt
price he says shout out to the guy that
does common sense soapbox if you all
know who that guy is you should get on
the show that's hilarious so common
sense soapbox is a second channel i have
it's a collaboration between myself and
the foundation for economic education we
just try to do educational cartoons
about economics so we just released a
video yesterday which is the second part
in a series we're doing trying to
illustrate the absurdity behind the
philosophy that led to the lockdowns
illustrated through an analogy where
characters are on an island so i highly
recommend you all check that out all
right reclaim the frame says if trump
were to win office again do you think he
would pardon those charged for january
6th
um
oh i'm sorry i just stepped right in
there i thought it was my question um
probably what is your question i i
believe that i believe that he
i don't know he says stop and then he
doesn't exactly exactly hold on hold on
let me back up here um i think that he
probably will for well he'll go with his
with his friends first anybody who got
in trouble
and then i'm sure hopefully he will
pardon the people with who were charged
with the lower crimes but i think he'd
have a hard time pardoning anyone who
was charged with um
attacking a police officer that sort of
thing even though those charges are
sketchy too he's got one
if he gets a lot if he gets if he gets
there's reelected i guess he's or he
gets elected again that's probably way
to put it uh he doesn't have to worry
about a re-election so he can just he's
off the leash he's going to be like
rubber stamp baby i'm doing what i want
i hope so i mean he left a lot on the
table yeah
he left us away he created a lot of
problems and he left left us with a big
mess and i'll say this even though trump
has certainly not kept all of his
promises
he would probably see it as
his prerogative to make an example out
of the people in the deep state who went
after him and his followers so i think
there's some reasonable hope that he
actually would pardon i have none of
that hope i i don't like the superhero
worship i think he's like just a corrupt
dude well i don't want power sure so but
but even feeling that way i think the
deep state is such an obvious enemy for
him that it would be
a really
straightforward move if that makes sense
but they just kill the president when
they try and oust the deep state like
kennedy if
if you try and take out the fbi director
who's been there for 40 years they're
like no no this is my government dude
you're only here for eight years as much
as most people probably you know look at
the jfk thing and kind of like you know
roll their eyes left and right it is
still getting a bit speculative to we
don't know exactly what went down with
any of this no the official story is
one guy did it all and then and that's
the problem is that i know
and then but it was like 40 minutes
after the execution and they found
oswald eating lunch in the building then
upstairs in the same building they find
his rifle with ammo he's just chilling
as if he put it there what idiot would
it would assassinate the president and
then leave his gun and walk
also yeah he's like what are you doing
i'm a patsy i mean i think he loaned the
gun to a group that had been doing some
like pro-castro stuff and they were like
hey let us borrow your weapons i don't
know conspiracy about all that but i
will say this when somebody assassinates
a political leader especially the
president of the united states like
they usually make a big deal out of it
and tell people what their political
demands are they leave a manifesto um
what's happening here very strange it's
a very unusual situation i think we have
the time right yeah
to litigate i'd love to see trump after
the deep state that's my point i just
don't see it happening but i'd like to
see it happen well uh i'll just say
whatever ends up happening in the future
hope everybody stays safe and i do think
you know we always need to remember that
the honking is working non-violent
civilized obedience is extremely
effective the the establishment
politicians are freaking out over the
great honking and we have a chance with
the upcoming primaries to get in a bunch
of uh america you know pro-america
individuals who push back on the
establishment i think that should be our
focus
so let's read some more yeah further all
right
jay says the honking reminds me of the
uh of that of the hype that came with
untitled goose game someone should alter
that game's logo to take the circle
cross out fly the honk and confuse the
sheeple have you guys played the goose
game yeah it is one of the best games
ever you play as a good just watching
around causing mischief
you are a goose you are a goose and you
like on what platform oh every platform
oh okay yeah so i mean like it's a it's
like a video game yeah it's uh that
video was like an isometric top down
yeah and there will be like there's like
a guy and he's farming and you run up
and just like honk at him and he gets
scared and then he drops his pail or
whatever and then you run around there's
like a little kid and you can chase him
honking and the kid's freaking it's just
so much fun to be the goose
hunk
everyone loves saying honk too because
honk was already a meme and now people
are honking and it's like honk
honk huh
hunk
all right
vasht says i mean if you want the
honking to stop you just got to stop the
mandates you don't even got to think
about it bro yeah exactly exactly trust
the experts you know the truckers know
what should be going in their body yeah
that's right man
i like what you said just comply yeah
nathan says heading into work wanted to
get a shout out to anna for our second
wedding anniversary oh that's lovely
good for you
warms my heart rv dl says hornk
let's get back to work
all right awm says i see ian rolled a 20
on his first statement
oh i felt that too
critical your point d
julian have you picked no i did not
think she'd if you roll a 20 on a
20-sided dollar this side of the table
is a critical success sorry no no
i avoided those so basically you're way
smarter than i was in d and d if you're
up if you want to do something and you
roll a one it's like the worst possible
failure okay and then if you wanted
something in your role 20 it's like
you've done it
perfect success so the joke is ian made
that he often makes statements that are
either a one or a 20. oh well now you
tell him i'm all in i swing at the
fences all right now i'm going to i'm
going to have that i'm going to say it
before we're done we're going to get a 1
or 20. yeah
hit a 20. hit a 20 every time um can i
give a quick shout out to your biggest
fan
liz sheld who is also my podcast partner
we only have a few
million less listeners than you do but
she listens to your show every day and
she told me what i had to wear today so
what the free the one sixers yes well
actually she wanted me to wear an ac dc
shirt or vanilla
i had a def leppard one but i wore this
instead but what's the podcast what's
the show it's called happy hour with
julian liz it's just basically to amuse
ourselves but um she
she loves she loves all you guys but
awesome all right let's let's read some
more free promo for
her fan fandom right on camel of the
mojave says karl marx got old and
acknowledged that capitalism solved all
the problems he complained about when he
was young and uh and as people not to
pay attention to his manifesto is that
true
sounds like something somebody would say
to like smear a person they didn't like
don't know
i don't know that makes it sound way
cooler to be honest yeah it does but
didn't people like say a bunch of stuff
about a bunch of figures like well
actually conversion story type things
are pretty common yeah yeah
all right
cox says one like equals one hunk hunk
from saskatchewan stand together and we
will free our children in the last five
months i have gone out zero times
besides work and this
yeah all right
all right let's see we got
daniel says ian's a.i reddit poster idea
was a cartoon skit worthy
there's like one robot it's like
brainiac from dc who's just like i will
control reddit to control the world it's
not far left enough why would you want
to control reddit
superman like breaks into brainiac's
headquarters and he's like brainiac what
are you doing i will control reddit and
take over your planet and he's like no i
can't stop him it's working
all right phil gohan says tim do you
recall when activists sees the canadian
railways in 2020. reservations were
demanding rcmp not police reserves
were uh reservations were demanding rcmp
not police reserves but were uh but were
they the upset with lack of policing
look where trudeau stood
some uh i'm not sure i'm understanding
correctly because of some grammatical
issues but uh i do remember when there
was a big protest with the uh the
reservations and all the stuff i mean
it's just obviously there's great double
standards here i mean you gotta you know
you gotta think about it bro yeah
eric miller says look at mao's great the
grape leap forward and compare it to the
great reset a lot of similarities yeah
they actually someone pointed out that
they're actually calling this year one
or whatever like was that pol pot year
zero or whatever yeah
a lot of people are they're they're
they're they're really calling this year
people were saying it's like year one
you know
after the pandemic or something i
believe i was thinking about changing
the year to like 13 000 and making zero
the day that the comet hit
12 800 years ago when the comet hit
north america there's so many stuff
would you like to the younger driest
period no which comment was the one that
caused the missoula flood but that was
what's the name i don't know the name of
it because i i probably could remember
what you're talking about by the time
because i read i was reading something
really cool that uh they were saying
that like uh gravitational shifts aided
in the slamming of the the oh
you know the meteor that killed the
dinosaurs or whatever
crazy stuff who knows though we are we
are but small specs on this planet
thinking we know so much
all right well i know so much i don't
know about you guys
mavis says tim you're right about the
democrats being desperate i saw an ad on
youtube today featuring pelosi begging
for money because republicans are out
raising and not spending democrats that
is correct money for what though what
are they spending this money on who
political advocates yeah 1.6 billion for
instance that oh my god
on ads yeah just tv ads ads it's it's
mostly advertisements but there's also
consulting there's consulting that's
where it gets like it's such trash like
hey how you doing good thanks for how
are you doing thanks for consulting yeah
but but political consulting is real
they'll so they'll call the farm and be
we're trying to get you know
middle-class white men what do we do and
they'll be like so we've got data from
the past five elections here's what
we're seeing here's the media and they
pay for it but uh a lot of it's ads
buying advertisements and that's why
when michael bloomberg was was running
it was crazy youtube ads youtube ads was
just oh everywhere we did a cartoon
about that for freedom tunes yeah oh
that yeah that that was crazy they were
really everywhere it was like if you
were on youtube you were like all of a
sudden i have a lot more money than i
should have had because michael
bloomberg dumped what like 500 million
dollars it was like 100 million to
digital but when
this this i'll tell you this you guys
this election season is going to be so
intense 2022.
youtubers in the political space are
probably going to make like three or
four times as much money as they
normally do really yup
every every ad slot will be filled it's
going to be nuts and then but it's going
to be non-stop for for uh in the middle
of this year we are going to see
political ads like it's it's already
going to start probably i mean you're
talking about nancy pelosi already the
midterms are this year so from like this
point forward we're going to see a
dramatic increase in revenue for all
youtubers and all websites and then 2023
is presidential primary and it is so
intense right now
it is going to be
i mean we're talking about fifth
generational warfare we're talking about
it's gonna be crazy you know i was money
is the people gonna be smashing the
getting the silverware and bailing off
the titanic that's what that makes me
feel like people scraping for ad revenue
talking about politics well because it's
not just congressional races i mean you
got governor's races in every major
state you know that's right midwest and
florida i mean you've got georgia so
it's not just those congressional races
it's i mean people are going to be
inundated
i wonder what republicans are going to
spend all that money on though that'll
be interesting to watch
billboards but where i mean super bowl
commercials what they're doing what
their message is going to be where
they're going to target it
that'll be interesting i don't know
dbz dragon says reading constitutional
law has taught me one thing it is
important to read your bible
but why is that huh
why is that sheamus do you have any
insights on why that might be with
constitutional law i mean why why why
that would lead someone to say read the
bible yeah like blackstone's formulation
that's true yeah that was part of it you
know when i read that i was kind of like
wow yeah well jordan peterson talks
about how the bible laid out how it was
possible for a slave to have as many
rights as a king which is one of the
things that they did put into effect
this is one of the laws that a doubt in
the even in the old testament which to
left loves to knock
brian beede says free hankistan
free hankistan
huh
all right
matthew hammond says can we get mark
levin on to discuss convention of states
he wrote the book the liberty amendments
that di discusses what needs to be
passed in the convention of states
i'd love to i mean he does his own show
but he's on sundays though right i think
so i mean if i i would be honored i'd be
great honor and a privilege
antonio gonzalez's borg bolsheviks
operating for repressive governments ha
ha
i love it the borg of organization
organization my thoughts the other night
bobby bob says the year is 2030. the
resistance is pinned down from over the
hill lily williams appears on horseback
robes flowing in the wind gold ar held
above her head freedom
she rides down the hill and the battle
is won oh my gosh but how old is lily
it's 20 30. it doesn't matter eight
years
i didn't say she wouldn't i'm just
saying is it going to be cyborg lilly
williams yeah that's not fair enough
yeah she's going to be she's going to
she's going to be like she's going to
have like a
cyborg you know she'd have like a laser
gun on her arm yeah
one eye and she's going to be like i am
freedom yes
williams
clint taurus says go lick a boot now
there's a t-shirt go lick a boot for our
canadian that's hilarious
so many good t-shirt ideas
maybe we can get a a website like you
know
the the really best political shirts.com
second the second best
that's too long
better than the other guys t-shirt
website dot com
perfect tiger says you wear a mask for
so long you forget who you were beneath
it v
well actually i'm pretty sure that's
alan moore but still a good quote
molan labe says it's not just january
6th defendant it's also two-way
community with arbitrary atf rule
changes guntuber crs firearms was just
arrested and charged with seven felonies
for a for a drawing machine gun and
obstruction for getting married please
look into it spread info whoa that's
crazy
dude i'm telling you guys it is going to
get really really bad this year
it's going to get really really bad
they're going to go after soft targets
first
uh easy you know political activists
members of the 2a community especially
they're going to do everything they can
to try and shut these voices down people
in media will probably get censored but
it's really really risky for
authoritarians to go after prominent
voices because it creates a splash and
that can create a massive ripple in
descent so what they'll do is when you
look at the censorship on twitter here's
a really easy way to understand this all
of the regular people with small
accounts who are tweeting learning to
code were getting banned when i tweeted
learn to code nothing happened i tweeted
learned to code several times like let's
see it come on they wouldn't they
wouldn't take me down for doing that
because it would prove everyone right
but these smaller accounts that had no
that didn't have the many followers were
disappearing one by one and i met a lot
of people at these events they were like
my account suspended all i did was tweet
learn to code
because if you're if you're you know if
you don't make a big splash they'll come
after you that's the that's that's the
crazy thing and what they do is they
erode the base then in five years when
the base is substantially weaker then
they can get rid of you know everyone
else
all right
darius says tim i think you may have
missed mine or i miss you talking about
mine last time but look into crs
firearms arrested for selling bottle
openers with diagrams of auto sears
really
it's like arresting someone for sharing
knowledge
crazy that's crazy
that guy says i can't help but notice
that the latest cnn scandal headline
repeatedly uses the word consensual i
guess they're trying to push the new
narrative that at least the newest
scandal wasn't criminal
yo how many scandals do they have now so
many months
that's
kind of crazy well i tweeted that i
really thought it would be lies that
took cnn down but apparently it was
going to be a mass inability to keep
their freaking pants on yeah it's
disgusting is it crazy that like uh far
left people like aren't really sexually
moral
i don't know that's good all right
that's crazy hugh says
uh long time listener tim love your
content you help me find meaning in this
meaningless world get kim iverson on
your show again we have had her on the
show and i think we're going to have her
on the show again right yep yes she
she's the like moderate lefty person who
recently tweeted she's voting straight
ticket republican because she's sick of
the mandates and i'm just like wow
there you go man more and more people
are like i am done with this we should
have her and botcha together that'd be
really cool
super cool
uh artindi says hey tim i saw will of
the people and it inspired me to turn it
into a mini video game it could be
played for free in browser on itch.io
under the same title hope you all enjoy
it ooh you want to check that out ian
yeah h dot io well of the people what is
it itch.io itch.io itch
so we're uh we're working on a sequel to
will of the people called pain
and we have a lot of the instrumentation
done already i just got the uh
a mix
and uh
i probably shouldn't say it but i'm just
gonna say it anyway i hit up phil
labonte and asked him if he wanted to
help with the lyrics and the vocals and
he said yes so i don't know if he can
though
but uh that'd be really really cool i
would be it would be an honor and a
privilege to be able to work on a song
with the the legendary philabonte so
that'd be super cool it's a video game
you said yeah
what do you do in the game
i don't know i don't know i'm just
looking at it now it'd be cool it was a
text adventure game i like this from
back in the day oh yeah like zork
yeah all right delhiopolis says tim why
does your impression of chris wallace
sound like your impressions of mitch
mcconnell because they're both turtles
right how would you how would you do uh
either of them seamus you know what i
don't have an impression for either of
them if i'm honest
james can't do it i just can't do it he
doesn't have the skills i'm just i have
the skills to pay the bills i just i
can't keep giving it away for free oh
that's fair that's fair
i haven't honestly i haven't heard
either either of them speak in a while
they're just they turtle voices or
strike turtle boys like kind of like
that i don't know i said chris walker
talk like this kind of yeah
i'm mitch mcconnell
am i not
and i i you know to be honest like chris
wallace is more turtley than mitch
mcconnell is but i i when i do mitch
mcconnell i make him very turtley
i have just like disdain for the man so
yeah well
all right john whitton says all they
have to do is park the trucks nose to
tail side by side lock the doors and
walk away and it would take the
government a month or more to clean up
the mess oh man
that's no joke man
rob says did you forget the rock also
commented on joe's post come on timmy
yeah the rock man
it's amazing to see
that that's victory man when the rock is
you know when the rocks what's what's
this saying what's rocks cooking or
whatever if you can smell what the rock
is going yeah can you smell it with the
rocket squishy i smell it today rocky
freedom
like i think i don't know where he wants
to go on the rogan experience no i think
i think what's happening is these
celebrities are relatively vapid
individuals but they're realizing joe's
winning yeah and so they're like yo i'm
gonna be with him
we always loved joe what are you talking
about
they're like if i'm gonna do a new movie
i need to go on his show i'm gonna be
nice to that guy yep
uh bon johnson says tulsa oklahoma
frozen over and my boss told me the
roads were clear saw cars smashing a
divider wall turned back i got stuck a
mile from our house currently walking
back home and watching the show hey man
don't don't freeze to death stay safe
try that dragon bath breath that vim
hoff method if you need warmth is that
this is that the sea sharp inhalation
then a strong accident was like breath
of fire yeah
you do that for like a minute straight
and your body temperatures apparently
you're going like a psychedelic trance
you get like six or seven seconds in
your body temperature kick up yeah
michael williams jr says more hong kong
talk about american convoy i want to see
it honk honk hong kong hong kong
free honk hunk
click the link in the chat free hong
kong go to timcast.com click the store
get your free hunk hunk shirt
it's like kind of hard to say if they're
really an unsafe otherwise it sounds
like you're saying free hong kong
exactly i know that is what i thought
you said free hong kong i was like
what's happening in hong kong what am i
missing right free hunk hunk punk it's
gotta be honk declarative i got a shout
out up there where someone said jordan
peterson's the man yes ridiculous said
it thank you
so you know that that ai that can
generate someone's voice
like they made they made one of
joe rogan they took it down but that's
that's actually kind of crazy if i was
someone like jordan peterson i would be
really scared of people like sheamus
because sheamus could you know say a
bunch of crazy things and then just put
it on the video and claim it was jordan
peterson what i do everyone would
believe it really that's what i do yeah
yo this is whoa whoa i just saw this
tony says dave portnoy is officially
suing julia black and business insider
for defamation in response to the most
recent hit piece published today with
penn earning call tomorrow dave portnoy
you're the man
i i wish you i wish you victory and
great fortune in going after i read that
story it was absurd i heard what dave
said yo these these people are
unscrupulous
they publish fake news and defamation
and they think they can get away with it
and i'm i'm glad to see dave is pushing
back
don't screw around you know don't these
people should not be screwing around and
i i hope dave wins
they smeared him uh it's been a while
since i read the story but it was just
so dumb
they do these things where like someone
claimed it was true therefore it is
and then he came out and he was like hey
i can rebut this and they don't take his
comments and stuff like that it's all
dirty dirty games man all right
everybody if you haven't already smash
that like button because one like is one
hunk
go to timcast.com become a member help
support our work we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you
around 11 or so p.m the uncensored
version extended extra half an hour of
the show and you can follow us at tim
cast irl basically everywhere you can uh
again subscribe to this channel on
youtube you can follow me at timcast
on instagram or any and anywhere else
julie do you want to shout anything out
um
just my book book it's available on
amazon i think barnes noble um
my work can be found at amgreatness.com
and just thank you for having me i
learned a lot so many things but i it's
a goose game for sure
thank you guys for having me
uh so i'm gonna plug my stuff here i
guess i have to be careful to make sure
this is zany and wacky enough for tim
who shamed me at the beginning of the
show
boy
shut up
i have a wacky youtube channel called
freedom tunes and tomorrow we're going
to be uploading a cartoon about justin
trudeau and the great honking so stay
tuned for that youtube.com freedomtunes
go over there watch it like share
subscribe i think you guys are gonna
love it uh you can follow me in
crossland.net check out my social media
there if you want to follow me all
around the internet great to see you
guys have a great night thank you guys
for tuning in thank you julie for coming
this wonderful conversation always going
to get experts on breaking news like
january 6 hearings i am sarah patrick's
on twitter and minds.com you can follow
me at either of those places we will see
all of you over at timcast.com become a
member check out the members only
segment thanks for hanging out bye guys
you